Treue Phoenix Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die kennen ihn vor allem auch
von afd-parteitagten aber auch von
anderen politischen Ereignissen
Professor Wolfgang Schröder von der
Universität Kassel und gleichzeitig
tätig fürs Wissenschaftszentrum in
Berlin wir wollen über die AFD als
solches noch mal sprechen auch über die
aktuelle wie auch die grundsätzlichen
Fragen hat die AFD denn ihren Höhepunkt
ihres Stimmen Zuwachses ihrer Resonanz
ihrer Zustimmung in der Bevölkerung
erreicht das ist eine offene Frage weil
wir hätten ja vor über einem Jahr gesagt
die AFD ist auf dem absteigenden Arzt
zwei Jahre nur Wahlen Niederlagen aus
einem Landtag herausgefallen wenn wir
vor einem Jahr die Frage spekulativ
angegangen werden hätten wir mit großer
Skepsis vor allen Dingen nach den
Ergebnissen des Riesa partei-
begutachtet wie es weitergeht und die
Entwicklung ist schwer einzuschätzen
weil klar ist die Unzufriedenheit der
Bevölkerung ist dramatisch hoch die
Herausforderung sind ebenso groß wenn
man jetzt mal schaut die wirtschaftliche
Krise fängt ja erst an die Frage der
Migration immer größere Bedeutung zu und
insofern ist schon zu erwarten dass die
eine Weile auf diesem Niveau fahren
können gleichzeitig ist es so dass
Regierungen in der Hälfte der
Legislaturperiode immer eher die
schlechteren Begutachtungen bekommen und
insofern kann man darauf hoffen dass die
Regierung sich natürlich berappelt und
in der Lage ist hier wieder eine bessere
Performance einen besseren Auftritt hin
zu bekommen das hätte auch einen
Einfluss auf die Zuneigung zu AFD und
beschäftigt sich die Politikwissenschaft
ja sehr stark mit Demoskopie mit
Statistik mit bezahlen wie groß ist denn
das Potential noch dass die AFD
erschließen könnte gibt es da
Gedankenspiele oder Berechnungen ja also
ganz interessant ist die
afd-wählerschaft setzt sich ja aus zwei
Hauptgruppen zusammen einerseits die
überzeugten die wirklich der Auffassung
sind also dieses System ist inakzeptabel
kompromisse sind so nicht
nachvollziehbar ist alles zu kompliziert
und im Hintergrund sind irgendwelche
Eliten die man nicht
vertrauenswürdig begleiten mag und dann
hat man aber diejenigen die er
konjunkturell an die Sache rangehen die
also merken dass läuft nicht so wie ich
mir das vorstelle ich verstehe das
gerade nicht und der Teil ist größer
geworden in den letzten Monaten und
interessant ist jetzt wo kommen die her
und die kommen nicht unbedingt stark von
der CDU von der SPD von der FDP in grün
sondern sehr stark aus dem nicht Wähler
Lager also Leute die eigentlich von
politischen System sich schon ein Stück
schnell wieder verschwinden die können
schnell verschwinden die können auch von
den anderen wieder gewonnen werden
insofern ist das sehr volatil was wir da
erleben
heißt es sind ja die man jetzt
protestwählerinnen und Wähler nennen da
gibt es ja auch ein Streit woher kommt
eigentlich oder was sind das für
Wählerinnen und Wähler die der AFD ihre
Stimme geben das heißt wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe diese
Protestwahl Verhalten diese Wut diese
Verärgerung über das was jetzt gerade im
Lande passiert ist schon sehr stark
unter dieser Wählerschaft vertreten die
jetzt vor hat es waren ja alles Umfragen
die wir gehört haben die jetzt vor hat
bei den nächsten Wahlen die AFD zu
wählen ja also erstens mal das haben sie
ja jetzt auch angedeutet ist natürlich
die Prognose ist nicht gleich das
Ergebnis aber es gibt so eine gewisse
Normalisierung dass man das gar nicht
mehr so dramatisch findet dass deine
Partei als rechtsextreme klassifiziert
wird dass da eine Partei als eigentlich
nicht regierungsfähig plastifizierte
sondern man schaut stärker auf die
Funktion die haben für uns die Funktion
den Protest deutlich zu machen die
anderen zu verschrecken und zu sagen so
geht's nicht weiter und das wird ja auch
das kann man an der CDU ja sehr schön
machen es gibt
politische zum Teil gefärbt gehört bei
den Linken heißt bei den bei den
Konservativen Liberalen heißt er also
das sind protestwälder die können wir
wieder zurückgehen die Linken sind da
eher skeptisch und sagen klarer Fall
wäre AFD wählt da kann sich nur um ein
rechtes Weltbild um neu Rechte oder
rechte Überzeugungen handeln was ist an
diesem Argument dran naja zunächst mal
die empirischen Umfragen zeigen ja dass
der Anteil geschlossen rechtsextreme
denkender und fühlender Menschen in
Deutschland zurückgegangen ist in den
letzten Jahren
erstens zweitens man muss natürlich
immer in Rechnung stellen dass wir ein
großes Potenzial von Menschen haben die
mit Politik wenig zu tun haben die aber
doch irgendwie Zugriff auf das
politische System haben soll in dem
Sinne so kann man das nicht machen und
so ist das falsch und dann sind schon
Werthaltungen dahinter die durchaus
problematisch sind im Bereich Rassismus
im Bereich Antisemitismus im Bereich
doch tiefgreifender Demokratie
Unzufriedenheit aber gleichzeitig ist es
nicht so geschlossen und verhärtet dass
man diese Menschen nicht wieder
zurückgewinnen könnte durch gutes
Regieren durch
vertrauensprozesse und eben durch eine
bessere Einbindung da spielt die
Zivilgesellschaft auch eine wichtige
Rolle weil man muss sehen diese
Veränderung die wir in den letzten
Jahren erlebt haben die es nicht einfach
durch Berlin zustande gekommen sondern
auch durch eine Schwächung der
Zivilgesellschaft durch eine Veränderung
der Medienlandschaft und das führt dann
auch zu Orientierungsproblemen die man
im früheren Jahrzehnten bei ähnlichen
Problemen langsam so nicht gehabt der
Erfolg hat der bekanntlich viele Väter
und Mütter Mütter und Väter der
bisserfahrung da will eigentlich keiner
für zuständig seine wollen aber die
anderen Parteien mal nicht aus der
Verantwortung entlassen Stichwort
ampelchaos ich nenne es mal so plakativ
was in die weit haben die an den
Mitschuld am Aufstieg der Aufstehen am
Aufstieg der AFD kann man das nicht so
klar klassifizieren aber deutlich ist
die Ampel hat einen Anteil weil die Art
und Weise wie sie ihre Gesetzesvorhaben
kommuniziert hat hat bei einem Teil der
Bevölkerung
Ängste aus und diese Ängste sind
natürlich zustande gekommen weil auch
Medien das sehr stark nach oben gekürzt
haben weil es entsprechende narrative
gegeben hat so eine SED die jetzt im
Keller nachschaut was für Heizungen man
hat die also den Eindruck erweckt da
wird ab nächste Woche schon eine andere
Realität gesetzt da werden enorme Kosten
auf einen zukommen wenn man das
frühzeitig angegeben hätte wenn man
Etappen baut wenn man soziale
Kompensation technologische Offenheit in
einem überschaubaren und etappenförmigen
Sinne angeboten hätte wäre dieses
Desaster so nicht passiert das heißt mit
anderen Worten die Regierung hat einen
Anteil und muss besser regieren werden
Stichwort schwingerkurs der Union
welchen Anteil hat das am Erfolg den
unfreiwilligen Anteil am Erfolg der AFD
wenn man das Interview von Herrn Merz
nimmt das sommerinterview dann kann man
ja Prozesse der Normalisierung
feststellen und diese Prozesse der
normalisieren sind ohne Not weil es ist
doch klar auf kommunaler Ebene da hat
man immer wieder ähnliche Positionen
aber in ähnlichen Positionen in einem
Verhältnis zu einer als nicht
demokratisch klassifizierten Partei ist
es doch ganz einfach zu sagen wir
stimmen genauso ab wie die wir haben
aber einen eigenen Antrag wir haben eine
eigene Begründung und sind infolgedessen
überhaupt nicht auf diese Gruppe
angewiesen wir werden auch mit dieser
Gruppe keine gemeinsame Sache machen in
dem Sinne dass wir die Ideen gemeinsam
entwickeln so eine Art Königsweg für die
anderen Parteien im kolonialbereich gibt
es ja auch wenig parteipolitische
Kontroversen wir wollen uns mal ganz
kurz die Frage in einem kurzen
Filmbeitrag Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer ansehen ob man und wie man da
die AFD möglicherweise mit ganz spitzen
Fingern anfässt oder ob man mit ihr
möglicherweise doch kooperiert oder auch
kooperieren muss Herr Professor Schröder
es gibt ja immer wieder diese die
Behauptung die AFD hätte es hingewiegt
so eine Art diskursverschiebung
hinzukriegen was vor zwei Jahren noch
riesen Schlagzeilen gemacht hat nimmt
man jetzt schulterzuckend hin ist da was
dran da ist auf jeden Fall was dran das
kann man in verschiedenen
Themenbereichen sehen im
Migrationsbereich ganz eindeutig
wenngleich man hier auch feststellen
muss das ist jetzt nicht die
Eigenleistung der AFD sondern Vorbehalte
gegen Migration Vorbehalte das ist zu
viele sind dass die falschen kommen und
so weiter gab es natürlich immer aber
die AFD hat es vermocht dieses Thema so
zu mobilisieren dass es weit über ihren
Bereich dann auch Resonanz und
handlungsfähig geworden ist hat man das
z.B auch in der Thematisierung des
öffentlich rechtlich ja immer von der
AFD das darf man in der Öffentlichkeit
gar nicht mehr sagen in dem Moment sagt
man ja eigentlich indem man das behaupte
das heißt also
in der Tat ist diese diskursverschiebung
in der Öffentlichkeit tatsächlich
spürbar die ist spürbar und ist für die
Demokratie auch ein Problem weil
demokratie lebt von Voraussetzungen die
sie selbst gar nicht so herstellen kann
im Augenblick und wenn diese
Voraussetzung permanent in Frage
gestellt werden dann gehen damit nicht
nur viele Probleme einher nervositäten
Irrationalitäten und viel Orientierung
aber das Prinzip der AFD ist ja um das
noch mal auf den Punkt zu bringen dass
sie sehr geschickt Probleme die ja real
sind aufgreift und sie zu universellen
Menschheit Herausforderungen
kristallisiert ohne aber selbst eine
Perspektive anzubieten wie man
konstruktiv mit diesem Problem umgehen
kann das gilt möglicherweise nicht für
alle Fragen was wird ja immer gesagt die
AFD ist halt zum Teil schon in der Mitte
der Gesellschaft angekommen das wird oft
mit einem kritischen Unterton versehen
jetzt eine neue Umfrage gesagt dass 42%
der Menschen Deutschland die
migrationspolitischen Überzeugungen der
AFD gut heißt das heißt dass die
Flüchtlingsströme nach Deutschland auf
jeden Fall
eingedämmt werden müssen 42 Prozent das
sind doppelt so viele wie in den
günstigsten Umfragen gerade die AFD
eigentlich wählen wollen das heißt bei
dem Thema ist die AFD tatsächlich in der
weitgehend in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
angekommen ich werde vorsichtig mit der
Formulierung in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft es gibt eine Zustimmung
wenn man sagt also da muss was getan
werden das kann nicht so weiterlaufen
aber wenn man dann in die Details
hineingeht sieht es auch schon wieder
anders aus und dieses Thema ist insofern
halt hoch problematisch weil wir ja eine
bestimmte Rechtsordnung haben wir haben
eine europäische Rechtsordnung wir haben
eine deutsche Rechtsordnung und auf
dieser Grundlage als Rechtsstaat müssen
wir handeln und wenn man der Auffassung
ist dass die bestehenden Rechtsnormen
nicht in der Lage sind die
Lösungsfähigkeit im gegenwarts Mensch
herzustellen muss man für andere Normen
kämpfen aber das wird man nicht dadurch
erreichen indem man sagt wir machen das
Land zu weil wir sind Exportnationen wir
sind stolz darauf dass es durch Schengen
eine Freiheit innerhalb Europas gibt und
man muss sich klar machen wenn man den
Vorstellungen der AFD folgen würde dann
wäre dieses Land eine kleine isolierte
Schutzburg in Europa und auf der anderen
Seite ist klar wir brauchen eine
Regulierung und das Land hat viel zu
spät die Regulierung begonnen also die
Debatten über das Deutschland ein
Einwanderungsland sein sollte und sich
entsprechend aufstellt die haben in den
80er Jahren begonnen das ganze ist aber
erst umgesetzt worden 20 Jahre später
und mithin hat dieses Land auch keine
richtige Disposition wie sie eigentlich
mit Einwanderung kreativ positiv umgeht
und weil wir ja einen älter werdendes
Land sind sind wir auf Zuwanderung
angelesen und Zuwanderung ist nicht
gleich Zuwanderung das heißt wir
brauchen Regulierung und da ist eine
ziemlich unübersichtliche Situation so
dass also wenn jemand hört das geht so
nicht weiter dann wird er sagen ja ja da
haben die alle vollkommen recht aber ich
würde es nicht einfach der AFD gut
schreiben ich würde auch nicht davon
sprechen dass sie in der Mitte so
präsent sind wie Sie das für sich
vorgeht zur Fakten Würdigkeit noch dazu
das 49% bei dieser Umfrage gesagt haben
sie leben die Migrationspolitik mit der
migrationspolitischen Ansichten der AFD
ab aber trotzdem das sind ja relativ nah
beieinander die Zahlenwerte und die
Ampel war ja auch nicht in der Lage sich
wirklich zu dem asylkomponist der
Europäischen Union zu bekennen gut wir
werden an dieser Stelle einen kurzen
Break machen bedanke mich erstmal bei
ihnen Wolfgang Schröder